[Musique]
John Shipton bonjour
bonsoir nous vous recevons aujourd'hui
pour une chaîne internet qui s'appelle
thinkerview nous sommes en direct est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement
thank Younes
je suis en France pour sensibiliser et
soutenir giulian dans son combat pour le
libérer du système judiciaire du
Royaume-Uni et du département de la
Justice des USA
est-ce que vous pouvez nous résumer la
situation de Julian qui est Julian et
qu'est-ce qui se passe en ce moment
chef de WikiLeaks et a commencé à
publier wikiliks en 2006 en 2010 les
documents révélés par la lanceuse
d'alerte chelsemening à l'époque connu
sous le nom de bradleymanning les
documents de la guerre d'Irak de la
guerre d'Afghanistan de guantana Boba et
la vidéo collatérale murder ont projeté
Julian sur le devant de la scène du
journaliste dans tout le monde
occidental
à la révélation de ses crimes depuis
2010 Julian est poursuivi par les
États-Unis
par le biais du système de justice
suédois mais aussi par l'intermédiaire
du Royaume-Uni ainsi que de l'Australie
son pays d'origine qui est complice par
son inaction
voilà la situation actuelle
de malveillance féroce
incessante de calomnie sans scrupule
et de N vicieuse qui ont harcelé Julian
particulièrement au Royaume-Uni et aux
États-Unis
[Musique]
la semaine dernière jeudi dernier nous
lui avons rendu visite en prison chaque
visite dure deux heures mais souvent il
n'amène pas giulian tout de suite je ne
sais pas pourquoi et nous avons attendu
40 minutes donc nous n'avons eu environ
que 45 minutes d'entrevue réel avec
Julian est-ce que vous pouvez nous
résumer son état de santé est-ce que
vous pouvez nous résumer ces conditions
détention
dans la prison de haute sécurité de
Bellemare c'est dans la banlieue de
Londres il n'y a que des terroristes des
assassins ou des violeurs
Julian vit enfermé dans une petite
cellule
22 à 23 heures par jour
ce traitement serait qualifié dans les
accords d'Istanbul comme un isolement
cellulaire cela s'est aggravé au cours
de la période de covid parce que
l'administration pénitentiaire a perdu
beaucoup de personnels qu'il avait peur
de tomber malade et les prisonniers
passent par conséquent plus de temps
dans leur cellules
mais la prison a aussi accordé plus
d'appels téléphoniques à Julian
j'ai donc pu parler à Julian fréquemment
avec une limite maximum de 10 minutes
par appel mais vous pouvez avoir 10
minutes attendre quelques heures et
téléphoner encore 10 minutes
quels sont les rapports que vous avez
avec l'administration française et en
particulier monsieur
Dupont-Moretti qui était censé être son
avocat
il y a quelques années lorsque
Dupont-Moretti a pris en charge le cas
de Julian en tant qu'avocat il a tenu
une conférence de presse où il y avait
24 caméras des services de presse du
monde entier
à ce moment
j'ai rencontré Dupont-Moretti mais
malheureusement j'ai un mauvais niveau
de français et Dupont-Moretti ne parle
pas anglais
donc les seuls échanges que nous avions
eu était par l'intermédiaire d'Antoine
veille qui a travaillé avec
Dupont-Moretti
maintenant que Dupont-Moretti est
ministre de la justice il a dû
évidemment abandonné le suivi juridique
du cas de Julian et Antoine weye que
j'aime beaucoup dirige maintenant la
défense de Julian en France
est-ce que la France vous a proposé une
assistante de quelques manières que ce
soit
des systèmes friends
l'aide à portée par la France
a consisté à ne pas se joindre à la
campagne mondiale de diffamation de
mensonges et de calomnie et
honteusement que la France s'en est
abstenu la France a connu ses propres
difficultés au cours des deux dernières
années
l'attention du peuple français et de sa
classe politique
a été portée sur la France elle-même et
sa position dans l'Union européenne la
géopolitique etc donc on ne s'attend pas
à grand chose
le fait de ne pas avoir attaqué Julian
fait de la France et de l'Allemagne
les principaux soutiens potentiels de
Julian
a songe a révélé énormément de choses
sur leur enseignement américain
contre notre pays
comment la France ne peut pas vous
apporter plus d'aide que cela alors que
Julian a révélé les écoutes de nos
présidents de nos entreprises clés de
nos deals
[Musique]
comment vous interprétez la passivité
intellectuelle de la France et la
passivité
technique d'assistance de la France
vous savez que les révélations faites
par WikiLeaks et Julian ont rendu un
grand service à la France
en lui permettant de comprendre sa
situation actuelle par rapport aux
États-Unis et au Royaume-Uni ainsi
qu'aux renseignements électroniques
britannique et à la NSA
c'est important et même vital car cela a
révélé que 5 des plus grandes
entreprises technologiques françaises
ont vu leur secret piller et que la
pointe de la technologie française
s'est retrouvé aux États-Unis dans 5
domaines essentiels
ont aussi révélé que la Banque centrale
européenne avait espionner et montrer
les efforts déployés par les États-Unis
pour influencer les réflexions de la
banque à leur profit
un autre scandale c'est l'ingérence dans
les processus électoraux français par
les écoutes de la NSA
enfin le coup de grâce c'est le piratage
du téléphone privé du président français
tout cela doit à mon avis alerter les
élites françaises
sur ces méthodes et les faire réfléchir
sur comment y mettre fin
à mon avis les élites ont maintenant
envers giulianassenge et WikiLeaks une
dette d'honneur qui peut être remboursée
et qui attend de l'être
l'honneur tel que je le comprends dans
le système culturel français est
vraiment important et respecter cette
honneur sera à mon avis et je ne
souhaite pas pontifier je parle comme si
nous étions des amis à table et que nous
parlions deux choses et d'autres cette
honneur sera essentielle pour amener la
France à une position où les intérêts
français peuvent être maintenus au
premier plan
cette honneur sera essentielle
à mon avis
pour amener la France
à une position où les intérêts français
peuvent être maintenues au premier plan
au-delà des associations géopolitiques
avec de grandes puissances
je souligne deux choses
l'Union européenne a augmenté les
capacités des trains de marchandises de
4270 tonnes à 5200 tonnes en améliorant
les attaches entre les wagons
il y en a un toutes les heures venant de
Chine
un train toutes les heures
5000 tonnes depuis le mois de juin avant
c'était un train toutes les deux heures
donc cela nous indique que l'avenir de
la France
réside dans une association vers
l'intérieur du continent
l'équilibre du continent c'est vraiment
déplacé vers une association
continentale plutôt que vers une
association transatlantique
afin que 5 jours vraiment je pense qu'il
est essentiel
de comprendre la réalité de
l'opportunité pour la France de
s'affirmer dans le leadership de
l'Europe sans vouloir offenser
l'Allemagne mais l'Allemagne dépend de
la France
géopolitiquement pour des raisons
évidentes vous savez à cause des
difficultés depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale
en fait toute l'Europe s'appuie sur les
compétences diplomatiques françaises et
son leadership dans l'Union
je pense que les États-Unis ont
seulement volé 90 milliards de dollars
ce qui n'est pas une petite somme mais
ils ont aussi volé
l'effort industriel de la France
la construction d'un sous-marin ce qu'on
m'a dit est plus complexe qu'une fusée
et la France a ses capacités
il y a là une verticalité industrielle
de la base la métallurgie jusqu'au
sommet l'électronique et la France a ses
capacités
j'ai une autre question concernant votre
attitude face à la surveillance que vous
devez subir tous les jours
votre téléphone
vos connexions Internet
les connexions internet et les
téléphones de vos amis
les gens qui peuvent vous suivre qui
peuvent vous épier vous surveiller
psychologiquement
comment vous faites pour
encaisser vous endurcir face à vos devis
privée qui se réduit comme [__]
[Rires]
et bien comme vous je n'ai plus de vie
privée vous parce que vous êtes à la
pointe de la diffusion en France
on vous surveille constamment
et donc je ne fais pas attention il me
surveille mais jusqu'à présent et grâce
à Dieu ils ne m'ont pas gêné
n'ont publié aucun scandale de mon passé
dans les journaux et jusqu'à présent
je ne fais pas attention
et je pense que vous non plus une fête
pas attention mais vous comprenez que
nous sommes surveillés
mais si nous allons trop loin dans notre
commentaire nous serons détruits
nous sommes prêts à être détruits nous
sommes français
nous sommes français et nous n'avons pas
de limite
si tu provoques un français le peuple
français c'est comme réveiller le diable
mais nos élites n'ont pas ce code
d'honneur
les Français se souviennent toujours de
ce code
effray
sans aucune flétrie de ma part vous
savez
depuis la prise de la Bastille
la France a été à l'avant-garde
pour trouver
des moyens
de sortir des problèmes
que les élites nous causent
mais je ne veux pas me faire d'ennemis
dans des élites parce qu'elles doivent
nous aider d'une manière ou d'une autre
car nous dépendons de leur décision
cependant
le fondement de chaque société moderne
l'Angleterre mise à part nos sociétés
sont fondées sur l'égalité la fraternité
et la liberté nous en parlons tout le
temps la démocratie le choix etc
et cela fonde notre attitude
nous vivons et nous travaillons avec la
conviction que nous avons une certaine
liberté une certaine égalité et que nous
avons un peu de fraternité
nous croyons à cela et quand on nous
l'enlève nous réagissons et les
premières personnes à réagir sont
toujours pour une raison qu'on ignore
les Français
et donc les gilets jaunes
ont 11 personnes tuées
je pense qu'il y a eu 1700 blessés
graves beaucoup de gens ont perdu un œil
et pourtant ils ont réussi
ils ont réussi
vous avez vendu votre maison
pour assurer la défense de Julian
Assange pour assurer votre campagne à
travers le monde pour toucher énormément
de personnes
en France on a l'habitude de dire
méfie-toi de celui qui n'a plus rien à
perdre
vous êtes prêt à aller jusqu'à où
j'ai vendu ma maison et maintenant je
loue une maison à la campagne où il fait
assez froid en hiver
mais ces choses ne sont plus des
préoccupations
tout d'abord je suis vieux je n'ai pas
de souci je n'ai pas de famille à fonder
je n'ai pas entretenir un foyer je
pourrais vivre dans une tente si je
voulais
donc je suis heureux comme ça et depuis
trois ans ma valise ne m'a pas quittée
j'ai été dans 50 pays j'ai été à Berlin
8 fois et ainsi de suite donc je ne
m'inquiète pas pour ça
je m'inquiète pas pour le covid j'agis
judicieusement je ne me fais pas
d'ennemis parmi les gouvernements ce
n'est pas mon travail de me faire des
ennemis mon travail consiste simplement
à trouver un moyen pour sortir giulian
de la c'est ça mon travail
en terme de
vaccination de soins
d'aide psychologie qu'est-ce que Julian
a accès à la vaccination accès aux
moyens de protection comme des masques
est-ce qu'il a assez de couverture
est-ce qu'il a été malade est-ce qu'il
est-ce que l'administration
pénitentiaire
fait suffisamment attention à sa santé
physique et mentale est-ce qu'il a une
aide psychologique
je ne pense pas je pense qu'il n'y a
aucune justification pour qu'un éditeur
journaliste et intellectuel qui l'a
enfin aucune loi soit enfermé dans une
cellule de prison de haute sécurité 22
heures par jour moi je ne le pense pas
pour ce qui est du suivi médical Julian
Assens dépend entièrement de
l'administration pénitentiaire s'il ne
veut pas prendre de médicaments c'est
inscrit dans son dossier qui est
présenté au tribunal
et s'il veut prendre un médicament c'est
également inscrit dans son dossier et
produit au tribunal
pour les vaccins il a été vacciné bien
sûr parce que tous les prisonniers de la
prison sont vaccinés on a le choix sur
rien
il n'a aucun contrôle sur son corps
ni sur rien d'autre
sa seule possibilité c'est de penser
un jour après l'autre et même une minute
après l'autre
le reste est sous le contrôle total de
l'administration pénitentiaire car c'est
une prison de haute sécurité
tout ce qu'un détenu fait dans une
prison de haute sécurité et surveillée
sa cellule est fouillée régulièrement
voilà la situation actuelle de Julian
est-ce qu'il y a des caméras de
vidéosurveillance dans sa cellule
je ne sais pas mais dans la salle des
visiteurs où il nous place quand je
rends visite à Julian
il y a au plafond une caméra tous les
trois mètres
les autres il les places sous un vide en
mezzanine sans caméra
mais nous il nous place toujours sous la
caméra haute définition qui permet la
lecture labiale
programme de lecture labiale haute
fidélité et nous sommes toujours placés
là donc je parle à Julian de cette façon
et quand je dois discuter de quelque
chose je parle comme ça pour qu'il ne
puisse pas lire sur mes lèvres
quand vous avez appris
que la CIA
avait comme plan
l'assassinat ou le kidnapping de Julian
Assange
quel a été votre réaction comment vous
avez compris
vous avez pas été surpris
[Musique]
es
à propos de la CIA je suis complètement
cynique je ne comprends pas pourquoi il
a fallu si longtemps pour révéler les
agissements de la
ciao
comment puis-je dire ça
je vais trouver OK
la CIA dirige maintenant les programmes
de drone les programmes de drone ont des
cibles
lorsque vous lisez qu'une fête de
mariage a été bombardée ou qu'un cortège
funéraire a été bombardé c'est ciblé ce
n'est pas accidentel ce n'est pas parce
qu'il voit un groupe de personnes
dansaient qu'ils ont envoyé des drones
et font tout exploser
ils détruisent les moments rituels d'une
société
les moments forts d'une société sont
lorsque deux jeunes se réunissent et les
ressources de la société sont mobilisés
et la culture vivante est
représentée par ces deux jeunes gens
s'unissant pour produire la prochaine
génération
c'est le point culminant de l'existence
humaine il prépare la prochaine
génération
la continuité de la culture et du culte
des ancêtres dans le sens où une
génération pousse la suivante vers
l'avant
et bien quand vous détruisez tout cela
vous détruisez la croissance intérieure
et la vie intérieure de cette société
ils savent aussi que l'autre rituel
d'une société est le cortège funéraire
où l'on remercie et on célèbre la vie de
la personne qui est morte et qui est
enterrée
alors on se rassemble tous et on dit
merci au revoir et on célèbre sa vie de
différentes manières certaines personnes
pleurent
d'autres comme les Irlandais boivent un
verre etc mais nous célébrons
il détruit cela il le détruise
ce que vous avez déjà pensé à prendre
les armes pour délivrer votre fils
[Musique]
quand on voit les services secrets faire
preuve de non
de nonchalance quand on voit des
tentatives d'assassinat quand on voit
une ambassade qui a été infiltrée quand
on voit la calomie quand on voit votre
équipe calomnier est-ce que vous êtes
pas dit à la française maintenant c'est
terminé
je vais faire mon groupe commando
et on va arrêter de passer moi
l'expression me chier dans les bottes
ça pourrait prendre plusieurs formes
mais une forme plus violente que faire
des kermesses écrire des pancartes
faire des sourires à des journalistes
qui en ont rien à faire
il y a une belle chose qui s'appelle la
patience et avec la patience tu verras
passer sur la rivière les cadavres de
tes ennemis
sur la CIA et ces politiques de ciblage
ce sont des politiques des politiques
on ne répétera jamais assez je le dis
trois fois pour appeler les forces de la
vie à témoin c'est politique
détruire 7 millions de personnes au
Moyen-Orient était une politique
provoquer 37 millions de réfugiés au
cours des 20 dernières années qui èrent
dans le monde à la recherche d'un abri
et ruiner les sociétés d'où ils viennent
et mettre en danger les sociétés dans
lesquelles il s'installe est une
politique
et bien sûr
je ne peux pas me mettre à penser comme
une arme à feu
étirée sur les gens
bien sûr je voudrais aller voir humilier
bien sûr je voudrais les voir chasser du
pouvoir
bien sûr je voudrais voir des politiques
décentes et j'aimerais voir que ces
institutions
qui s'aiment tellement la mort se met
enfin la vie
quelle absurdité cette situation
j'aimerais vraiment que les choses
soient différentes
et j'y travaille à ma manière simple et
modeste oui je pense que cela répond à
votre question je ne suis pas sûr est-ce
que vous avez pensé à faire une grève de
la faim
pendant trois semaines
mais j'ai beaucoup maigri
ce n'était pas une chose très sage à
faire
mais je suppose que j'aurais pu car j'y
ai pensé
j'ai pensé à l'auto immolation vous
savez me brûler vif
j'y ai pensé mais cela m'a semblé en
quelque sorte contre-productif
il détruisent Julian donc je me détruis
et eux ils continuent à détruire du lien
de plus j'ai une fille grande comme ça
elle s'appelle Séverine
que deviendrait-elle
donc nous sommes coincés
nous faisons juste de notre mieux
comment dire
nous faisons absolument tout ce que nous
pouvons et nous restons raisonnables et
humains c'est notre travail
sans cela nous ne sommes rien
nous serions comme ceux qui approuvent
un nouvel instrument juridique pour
torturer davantage
qui se réunissent et discute sur comment
faire pour détourner l'attention de cet
événement la persécution de
giulianassage loin des crimes que nous
avons commis et faire en sorte que
l'accent soit mis sur la personne de
Julian d'accord c'est comme ça qu'on va
faire
on va faire ça on va suggérer à la juge
qu'elle décide de ne pas extrater Julian
Assange vers l'Amérique parce qu'il est
malade
et donc tout le monde se concentre sur
giuliane hassenge et pas les 7 millions
de personnes qui ont été massacrées pas
le chagrin et le deuil qui plane comme
un nuage noir sur tout le Moyen-Orient
pas les 77 millions de personnes à la
recherche d'un abri
pas le million de personnes qui se sont
réfugiées en Allemagne
à la recherche d'une nouvelle vie pas
les 500 000 qui se sont réfugiés en
Italie à la recherche d'une nouvelle vie
pas les 650 000 qui sont passés par la
France à la recherche d'une vie quelque
part pas ça donc il nous tout le monde
se concentre sur la personne de Julian
vous savez qu'il souffre et qu'il
pourrait se suicider
et vous avez une audience de deux jours
avec le juge en chef de la Haute Cour
d'Angleterre où on aborde que le sujet
de la santé de Julian
au lieu de regarder les crimes et le
rôle de la CIA que ces personnes ont
commis au cours des 20 dernières années
et qui ont été révélés par WikiLeaks et
Julian Assange
qui sont les crimes contre lesquels nous
nous battons
si Julian est extradé vers les
États-Unis si l'Angleterre laisse faire
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire
je déménagerai aux États-Unis et
continuera à me battre je ne sais pas
je ne peux pas abandonner je veux dire
non je n'ai pas pensé à céder je
n'utilise pas l'espoir comme un outil
je n'utilise pas l'optimisme comme un
outil
je fais face chaque jour je combats au
mieux de mes capacités chaque jour bien
sûr il y a des jours meilleurs que
d'autres vous savez certains jours on
est bon d'autres moins mais c'est ce que
je fais je n'utilise jamais l'espoir
comme un outil d'énergie
je donne de l'espoir aux autres bien sûr
je n'aime pas être méchant
mais je n'utilise pas pour sortir du lit
je sors du lit parce qu'il y a
énormément de choses à faire
quand est-ce qui est attendu la décision
britannique sur la demande d'extradition
des États-Unis
après l'audience des 27 et 28 octobre
2021 un avocat devant le tribunal m'a
dit que c'était une question de semaine
puis un autre avocat m'a appelé et il
m'a dit au moins 6 semaines puis j'ai lu
dans le blog de Alexander Mercouri que
ce serait à la mi-janvier
donc c'est très difficile à savoir
quels sont les recours si le Royaume-Uni
accède à la demande à cette demande
d'extradition
si l'extradition est acceptée en appel
Julian fera appel à la Cour suprême si
l'extradition est refusée
les États-Unis feront également à peine
après 2 ans de détention provisoire
Julian a le privilège si on peut appeler
ça ainsi de faire appel à la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
demander une mise en liberté sous
caution
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
décidera et probablement dire à oui plus
que probablement
validera sa sortie sous caution mais
cette décision n'est pas contraignante
pour le Royaume-Uni qui peut les envoyer
baladés
il y a un groupe de travail à l'ONU sur
la détention arbitraire dont la
conclusion en 2017 était que Julian a
été arbitrairement détenu ils ont
confirmé leur conclusion dans des termes
encore plus forts en février 2018
dans les deux cas le Royaume-Uni a
répondu ça ne nous intéresse pas
de même Niels Melzer le rapporteur des
Nations Unies sur la torture professeur
de droit international à l'Université de
Glasgow a publié un rapport indiquant
que giuliane était soumis à des tortures
psychologiques depuis 10 ans
et il a qualifié la situation de meurtre
au ralenti sous nos yeux
et
il a fait venir à la prison
de psychiatre spécialisé pour examiner
et aussi des médecins spécialisés sur
ces questions Dieu process il a décrit
des irrégularités de procédure et la
violation des droits de l'homme subit
par Julian
aussi les conventions d'asile
tout ceci particulièrement les
irrégularités juridiques sont décrites
dans son rapport et les Anglais ont dit
ne pas être intéressés
il a été autorisé à se marier
comment vous interprétez le fait qu'il y
ait eu des freins à cette union
c'était une demande administrative faite
par Julian Estella au gouverneur de la
prison
peut-on se marier
demande également faite au ministère de
la Justice peut-on se marier
la réponse a été retardée et retardée et
retardé donc les avocats de Julian ont
dit nous vous poursuivrons au tribunal
après une certaine date
24 heures avant cette date ils ont dit
oui
un avocat m'a appelé un ami proche qui a
dit John ils auraient perdu s'ils
avaient été devant les tribunaux
ils n'ont donc réagi que par force
majeure
sans aucun autre sentiment que
l'exercice du pouvoir
et c'est cohérent avec le traitement que
le Royaume-Uni a réservé à Julian
hassenge
si je peux me permettre
je pensais que tout cela provenait des
États-Unis
que les États-Unis
étaient ceux qui tiraient les ficelles
mais j'ai changé d'avis
parce que
pendant 12 ans le Royaume-Uni a fait
preuve de malveillance
comme d'habitude nous l'avons vu la
semaine dernière
dans différents sur la pêche
méchanceté sauvage sans scrupule des
mensonges scandaleux et des calomnies
pendant 12 ans
quand il manifester d'autres que de la N
vicieuse Julian comme vous le savez
base une partie de sa philosophie
sur la transparence
il déteste ça avec une haine vicieuse
ils attaquent la transparence
ils disent oui oui
mais alors vous demandez les pièces du
dossier au service juridique de la
Couronne qui a entre 9000 et 11000 pages
sur Julian
et vous n'en obtenez que 350
il déteste la transparence
chaque mois chacun des rédacteurs en
chef des principaux journaux et chaînes
de télévision du Royaume-Uni
se réunissent au ministère de la Défense
pouvez-vous imaginer qu'il se réunissent
dans le bâtiment même du ministère de la
Défense
les informe sur les affaires sensibles
en cours
de la façon dont leur propre terme
le ministre de la défense comme aide à
la production d'information et
transparence
mais c'est en fait un contrôle
supplémentaire car vous savez que le
Royaume-Uni a des avis dinotaïs
vous pouvez dire à personne que vous
avez reçu un dinota ni dire quel est le
sujet du dinota
et vous dise oh vous avez eu telle
conversation avec John chipton désolé
vous ne pouvez dire à personne que vous
avez eu cette conversation c'est
interdit vous ne pouvez pas publier la
conversation qui est contraire à la loi
et vous risquez la prison au revoir
c'est comme ça qu'ils font
est-ce que vous avez déjà ici de vous
mettre dans leur tête
est-ce que vous avez déjà
essayé de comprendre leur psychologie
est-ce que vous avez déjà essayé de
comprendre leur dessin
qui soit dit en passant est à l'hôpital
avec une pneumonie
je m'inquiète pour lui car c'est un ami
très proche
vous pourriez lui envoyer vos
salutations si vous avez le temps je
vous donnerai son adresse email
avec son aide et celle de John Le Carré
qui est décédé récemment son dernier
livre nous informe sur
il ne nous le diront pas
mais sur le portrait
d'une certaine couche de la haute
bourgeoisie du Royaume-Uni
parce qu'il produit
notamment en littérature
donc vous avez John Le Carré vous avez
grim green
Ian Fleming George Orwell
tous préoccupés par la duplicité
l'espionnage le silence on aime tous le
silence parfois la tromperie
le sacrifice et la trahison
tous ces livres traitent de cela
et c'est un courant littéraire
très visible en Angleterre
en Angleterre pas au Royaume-Uni
très différent disons de la France avec
Alexandre Dumas par exemple
donc vous voyez la force de ce contrat
où le penchant français
dans la littérature
vers l'élévation romantique
au dessus des difficultés de la vie
afin de les transcender
vous pourriez dire que c'est romantique
je ne le fais pas mais les gens le font
à l'Angleterre
au règne une imbrication complexe de
tromperie de silence
de trahison
ou la duplicité est un très répandu
comment
vous anticipez l'avenir du autre duo de
votre âge comment quel regard vous avez
sur la société après avoir traversé
toutes ces épreuves et comment vous
voyez l'avenir pour vos petits-enfants
oh
et bien vous savez pour le moment
je ne suis pas optimiste pour l'avenir
de l'Occident ou de l'Europe
parce que la force des perspectives
c'est déplacer vers la Russie qui se
reconstruit et la Chine qui est un mode
de gouvernement différent ou la finance
est un service public
alors qu'en Europe la finance est un
service privé d'où l'accumulation de
capital et la financiarisation de nos
sociétés
ce n'est pas encourageant pour moi de
penser que ma petite fille ma fille
passera sa vie
à payer une hypothèque au remboursé un
créditation délibérée de la valeur de
l'immobilier
on dit immobilier mais il s'agit d'une
inflation du prix des maisons
maintenant Amel Bourne il y a une telle
pénurie de maison qu'il y a des pages
facebook pour que les jeunes trouvent
des colocations
vous savez sur facebook aimeriez-vous
cohabiter et ainsi de suite et offre des
colocations
les jeunes n'ont plus assez d'argent
pour s'installer tu ne peux pas fonder
une famille
il n'y a pas assez d'argent donc tu dois
vivre avec ta mère avec ton père et tu
ne peux pas fonder une famille
en Allemagne par exemple
39% des femmes de plus de 40 ans n'ont
pas d'enfants
en français similaire je suis désolé de
le dire
en Italie c'est encore pire
les gens ne peuvent plus fonder une
famille c'est un désastre
est-ce que vous avez été un projet par
des services de renseignement extérieur
à ceux des États-Unis d'Angleterre
j'ai deux amis qui
ex secret
australiens
pas exactement les services secrets
devant
soyons précis
une des techniques est de détourner
notre énergie vers des impasses allez et
faites ceci et nous vous donnerons de
l'aide et de l'argent mais allez-y et
faites ça
m'est arrivé aux États-Unis
je n'y ai pas prêté attention
ça m'est arrivé au Royaume-Uni
mes deux amis qui sont dans l'un ou
l'autre aspect des services secrets en
Australie sont très francs serviables et
prudent
on dit tout le temps que
il y a une légende urbaine chez les
journalistes
qui est que la Russie avait prévu
dextiltré de Julian depuis l'ambassade
de Hard depuis l'ambassade d'Équateur
que c'est vrai c'est pas vrai c'est
encore des journalistes qui se sont fait
monter la tête
car il est toujours là et puis les
Russes sont des gens très compétents
je ne suis pas trop sûr quand vos
regardez ça lisbury ils n'ont pas fait
les choses proprement
touriste
j'ai vu des photos d'eux dans un avion
l'autre jour pétrole et borosov
c'est quand même
entier et c'est devenu ridicule
de même les Russes exfiltrant Julian
hors de l'ambassade
dans quel but et à quelle fin
veuille
la Russie possède un corps diplomatique
très compétent et opérationnel de
premier plan mondial en ce moment
la France était autrefois au premier
rang
la Russie qui est au premier plan
exfiltrantes Julian et risquant une
fusillade devant harods c'est juste un
délire un délire complet
il y a quelques années quand Julian
recevait beaucoup de visiteurs à
l'ambassade
on disait qu'il y avait un trou dans le
sol qu'il sortait et entrait
un des tunnels sous arrod parce que sous
arrose il y aurait beaucoup de tunnels
et donc qu'il sortait par ses tunnels
pour aller en boîte de nuit c'est juste
un fantasme que les gens fabriquent
avec ça quand vous voyez là la couardise
je sais pas si notre traducteur va
pouvoir traduire ça
la couardise de notre de notre
gouvernement le manque de courage
ce côté veule et est très politicien de
faire semblant de s'occuper des choses
est-ce que vous avez un message à leur
faire passer
yes
la substance et la force d'un
gouvernement
c'est l'unité du peuple derrière lui
c'est vital
la seule force d'un gouvernement c'est
la force de son peuple
pas ses arrangements pas boire du
champagne avec cette femme qui est venue
à Paris l'autre jour je ne me souviens
plus du nom Harry quelque chose comme ça
ce pays qui ment tout le temps
oui c'est ça ils ont bouclé tout le
quartier pour qu'on ne puisse pas
circuler alors qu'elle était en visite
un ministre d'État de la France buvant
du champagne avec un autre ministre
d'État États-Unis ou autre ce n'est pas
ça qui fait la sécurité et l'unité d'un
pays
la sécurité et l'unité et la force du
pays sa sécurité repose sur sa
population son éducation sa santé sa
confiance en l'efficacité du
gouvernement
et la conviction que le gouvernement ne
se dégonfle pas
fera pas preuve de l'acheter face aux
menaces et aux intimidations qu'il
trouvera un moyen par ruse fourberie ou
mensonge
trouvera un moyen de protéger le pays
plutôt que de dire bon d'accord vous
pouvez acheter la moitié seulement du
pays mais pas plus ce genre de faiblesse
de l'acheter et nous comprenons tout
cela
au gouvernement et nous occupons nos
esprits avec des distractions
et le gouvernement s'en rend compte
et quand ils doivent faire des choses
vraiment importantes comme organiser une
pandémie une réponse à une pandémie et
amener les scientifiques à examiner la
pandémie de près
d'évaluer les statistiques et d'amener
d'autres scientifiques à évaluer
pourquoi les États-Unis veulent que le
monde entier se vaccine
pour quelques raisons que ce soit pour
quelques raisons que ce soit notre
croyance dans le gouvernement que ça va
se passer comme ça donnera de la force
au gouvernement
de les instituer nous y croirons nous
les mettrons en œuvre nous l'aiderons
après j'en veux pas insulter les gens
mais après Hollande couille molle ou
Sarkozy qui veut tellement être
président qu'il dit je vais faire un
accord avec vous
pouvez prendre le commandement de la
force de frappe de l'Otan et je peux
être président
je pense qu'il était connu comme Sarkozy
l'Américain
on a d'autres noms mais on va pas les
dire ce soir
[Rires]
question d'internet la plus grande leçon
que nous que nous donne les profs subis
par son fils n'est-elle pas que la
vérité est incompatible avec l'idée de
nation
n'est pas la plus grande peur de ces
tortionnaires
je ne pense pas
la plus grande peur
des personnes qui torturent giuliane et
qu'il soit tenu coupable de leur crime
c'est leur peur
ils veulent pouvoir se lancer dans ses
aventures meurtrières
sans risquer de punition
c'est leur peur
sont d'ordre pratique pas théoriques
je ne pense pas qu'ils connaissent le
sens de la vérité
sauf pour dire bon c'est vrai que tu
sais que ma femme sort avec quelqu'un
d'autre vous savez je ne pense pas qu'il
sache que la vérité franchement question
d'internet pour quelle raison principale
pensez-vous que la France n'a jamais
offert l'asile à Julian
ni la Russie
mais bien la raison principale je pense
et que la France
avec d'autres nations
croyait qu'il y aurait une solution
pratique
diplomatique trouver par le Royaume-Uni
et la Suède
mesure les États-Unis
parce qu'en 2010 le vice-président Biden
a dit que cette affaire allait
embarrasser le premier amendement de
notre Constitution
donc nous ne voulons pas faire ça
je pense que les gens ont attendu
et au final mais ils ont attendu trop
longtemps
parlons comme j'imagine la France
je pense que
le ministre de la Justice du
gouvernement de Hollande
a discuté publiquement
de l'asile pour Julian
les allées du pouvoir en France
mais
les opportunités et le danger de cette
offre ont augmenté depuis que nous avons
assisté à un engagement de plus en plus
important du Royaume-Uni et des
États-Unis pour détruire Julian et
détruire l'idée de placer sur internet
des données qui permettent la naissance
d'un forum parmi la population
où les gens se rendraient pour faire
leur propre analyse et arriver à des
conclusions les leurs et celle de leurs
amis la famille leur communauté plus
large leur électorat qu'ils ne veulent
pas de ceci ou qu'il préfère cela
conserver cette information sur Internet
créer un forum de discussion géant
accélère notre compréhension
vous pouvez voir les résultats si je
peux passer en revue
l'année dernière je vais essayer de le
faire d'une manière intéressante
donc les dossiers de Guantanamo
collatéral murder où nous avons vu le
meurtre de 18 personnes les fichiers sur
la guerre d'Irak les documents de la
guerre d'Afghanistan ils ont eu un effet
sur la population des États-Unis et les
pays anglophones bien plus grand que sur
les populations non anglophones
et imprègne le sol de la culture
les empires réagissent très lentement
mais imbibant le sol
la culture
cela a provoqué un résultat
et ce résultat s'est manifesté de deux
manières
du peuple un aphorisme qui a surgit
comme un fait historique des guerres
sans fin ce n'est pas venu d'en haut
c'est venu d'en bas pour décrire une
réalité objective
une circonstance politique
résultant d'une action de l'état des
guerres sans fin
petit à petit la population a retiré son
soutien à mesure qu'elle devenait
Pacifique pas anti-guerre pas progaire
mais
Pacifique
nous ne voulons pas de guerre ça suffit
les guerres ont pris fin celles
d'Afghanistan a pris fin ils se sont
retirés ce qui fut un désastre pour eux
mais génial pour nous
la guerre d'Irak aussi c'est fini ils
sont partis
Guantanamo est presque fermé 80
personnes y sont encore ils ne trouvent
pas de place pour eux mais ils veulent
la fermer cette excroissance immonde sur
la face de la justice dans ce monde
ils sont sur le point de partir et
d'être vaincus
le désastre de la Libye est reconnu par
tout le monde maintenant comme une
tragédie
les leçons de la Libye envers les autres
nations du monde
qui reconnaissent maintenant qu'elle ne
peuvent pas laisser ces gens faire tout
ce qu'ils veulent ils doivent respecter
les lois
que c'est révélations
on pourrait faire d'arrêter les guerres
de la zone verte de Bagdad au
Département des terrains
il a été publié par WikiLeaks également
publié bien sûr par le site de Crypton
de John news et également publié par le
magazine fright parlons de celui-ci un
groupe de soldats américains est entré
dans une maison avec une famille
complète et a tué tout le monde les
enfants les mers les pères les oncles
les tentes les frères les sœurs ils ont
tué tout le monde
craignant de se faire prendre pour ce
crime ils ont ordonné une frappe
aérienne sur la maison et ont effacé
pour toujours toute trace de l'existence
de cette famille
cela a été décrit dans un document qui a
été élu par les membres du Parlement
irakien
et d'une manière par on ne sait qu'elle
magie le Parlement de ce pays détruit à
rassembler le courage la force de la
volonté le cran et a dit
nous ne signerons pas l'accord sur les
forces armées
le sofa nous ne s'ignorons pas
tout soldat américain tout soldat allié
de l'Amérique et ses alliés qui commet
un crime en Irak sera jugé pour ce crime
point final
et ils ont retiré les troupes une
révélation a arrêté une guerre vraiment
importante une révélation a arrêté la
guerre en Irak et ils ont dû s'y prendre
ensuite d'une manière différente en
soutenant easy c'est tout cela
mais une révélation à arrêter une guerre
votre travail de journaliste peut
arrêter des guerres
un autre exemple
les câbles couvraient aussi l'expulsion
des habitants des îles tiagos tous y
compris les chiens ont été enlevés des
îles tchagos et balancé à l'île Maurice
une des îles a été cédée aux États-Unis
pour y construire une base aérienne que
nous connaissons tous comme Diego Garcia
les habitants de l'île de tchagos et
leurs avocats ont vu le câble et ont
attaqué le Royaume-Uni devant la Cour
internationale de justice et ont gagné
le Royaume-Uni a fait appel mais ils ont
gagné à nouveau et sont en train de
demander une indemnisation
un autre exemple
un avocat américain qui vit en
Angleterre Clive Stafford Smith a créé
une ONG appelée reprive qui s'efforce de
faire sortir les prisonniers de
Guantanamo
comme vous le savez la plupart des
personnes qui s'y trouvent sont
innocentes de tout crime
ont révélé qu'un citoyen anglais
britannique était torturé en se faisant
couper le pénis en morceaux
il a pu plaider pour la libération des
personnes
c'est une autre situation
donc
arrêtez les guerres
rendre la justice
rendre la justice et indemniser les
habitants de l'île tchao
et finalement sur l'environnement
cette histoire est moche
a publié un article à propos d'une
société anglaise une compagnie
britannique qui a pris les déchets
électroniques et les a déversés au large
des côtes africaines
un empoisonnant la pêche une centaine de
personnes je crois que c'est 127 excusez
moi ma mémoire des chiffres n'est pas
précise
les villages ont été détruits car les
habitants ne pouvaient plus se nourrir
mais 127 sont morts empoisonnés se
vidant les boyaux incapable de marcher à
cause de la détérioration de leur
système nerveux
vous savez leur nerf ne fonctionnait
plus
cela a été publié et a permis aux
avocats et aux ONG d'aider et de
demander des indemnisations
et le déversement de déchets
électroniques au large des cotes
africaines à cc
vous avez sûrement du lire la partie sur
abougrahim et la partition Guantanamo
sur les techniques de torture
employées par les États-Unis
quels sont pour vous la pire chose que
vous avez pu lire
fait sur des hommes par d'autres hommes
vous savez
la pire
est-elle les notes de John new qui était
le ministre de la Justice des États-Unis
que la torture est acceptable
tous les pays du monde les Nations Unies
l'Amérique elle-même avait interdit la
torture
et là on a John new le ministre de la
Justice des États-Unis du gouvernement
bouche de qui essaye de convaincre que
la torture est acceptable à leurs yeux
de cela a découlé l'ouverture des sites
clandestins en Pologne des sites
clandestins en Ukraine et ailleurs
pour parler d'un cas concret de torture
il y a celui de calife qui a été soumis
à 84 séances de waterboarding une
simulation de noyade et qui a
complètement perdu la tête et est devenu
un zombie
n'est pas de vous faire avouer quoi que
ce soit mais de vous faire avouer une
chose précise
les gens ne réalisent pas que le but de
cette torture est de vous faire dire une
chose particulière
que ce soit pour dire qu'ils ont fait
exploser des tours ou n'importe quoi
d'autre que les sadiques ont en tête
mais ce que j'ai trouvé
particulièrement écoeurant
c'est la promotion du sadisme
comme politique du gouvernement des
États-Unis
aux États-Unis ou du mot gouvernement
américain
c'est la loi de la vie vous savez il n'y
a qu'une seule chose que vous ne pouvez
pas pardonner
c'est les attaques contre les enfants
le reste vous pouvez le pardonner c'est
humain mais attaquer les enfants c'est
impossible c'est au-dessus de mes moyens
je ne peux pardonner est-ce que vous
question d'internet a-t-il des
communications avec les candidats à la
présidentielle pour leur demander de se
positionner sur l'asile en France de
Julian Assange
avec les politiciens que des
conversations privées et de ne pas les
rencontrer si possible
je travaille
je travaille à partir de la base
c'est mon travail vous savez de
travailler de la base
vers le haut
je laisse ces négociations avec les
politiciens et les hauts fonctionnaires
à d'autres personnes qui par exemple si
vous proposez une certaine chose
une certaine voie
que Julian doit emprunter pour disons
obtenir un visa
on sait que ça pour demander l'asile en
France
si on propose ça il y a des mécanismes
la connaissance
de ces mécanismes
la connaissance des techniques
administratives
la connaissance des lois et des
règlements dans lesquels cela
s'inscrirait je ne les ai pas
c'est une affaire de professionnels
donc si le travail que nous faisons
depuis la base crée une condition
politique suffisante pour que les
professionnels puissent trouver une
solution au problème dans le contexte
opérationnel d'un travail sur les lois
de penser au moyen diplomatique pour
sauver la face ça c'est leur travail
mon travail à moi c'est de vous parler
ici
pour nous on vous donnerait l'asile tout
de suite
parce qu'il y a pas plus français qu'un
Giuliana sont en fait
c'est un bon sujet et on peut commencer
par là
c'est selon ton a parlé au début il y a
une heure et demie
a été enregistré pour la première fois
en France
pour publication en France
Julian vivait à l'époque dans le marais
et il avait une famille française
il était sur le chemin du retour en
France pour retrouver sa famille
lorsqu'il a été arrêté au Royaume-Uni où
il se trouve maintenant depuis 13 ans
c'est long pour traverser les 35 km de
la Manche ça fait 12-13 ans maintenant
j'ai un petit enfant en France et je
suis préoccupé
j'aime être ici
des gifs
on peut passer au cadeau que Julian et
WikiLeaks ont fait aux élites de la
France et par conséquent au peuple
français
les sujets que nous venons de couvrir
rapidement
on écoute par la NSA des appels
téléphoniques du président français même
des appels privés
à sa femme pour lui dire est-ce qu'on
peut avoir une bouteille de vin au dîner
ou autre des conversations privées
la manipulation du système électoral
français ils ont révélé commence là
était accomplie et quand cela a été fait
la manipulation de la Banque centrale
européenne
mon Dieu tellement important
la révélation de la NSA et du gchu
facilitant le vol et le pillage des
meilleurs éléments de la technologie
française
dont cinq entreprises vraiment vitales
donc vous savez Julian
est la France
en France on a vu les Américains
s'initier sur le deal des sous-marins
on aurait pu attendre comme mesure de
rétorsion de la France qu'elle donne
l'asile à
comment vous expliquer qu'on est
toujours pas fait c'est à cause du fait
que la France est dépendante en termes
de renseignement américain
ou c'est à cause que la France ne serait
pas ou ne sera pas capable d'assurer la
sécurité de Julian sur son propre
territoire contre les services secrets
américains qui tenteraient de
lassassiner
la ville de giulian je pense qu'elle
peut le faire
Corsica
une Corsica
car les Corses ont un code de l'honneur
je crois qu'il y a eu 17 tentatives
d'attentats contre le général de Gaulle
pendant qu'il était Président c'est
tentatives ont été déjouées par un
criminel Corse et ça garde rapprochée
était organisée par un homme qui était
haut en couleur
donc je crois que Julian serait plus ou
moins en sécurité ici
quels sont les arrangements que le
président de Macron et ses conseillers
en politique étrangères ont réalisé avec
les États-Unis sur le vol de 90
milliards de dollars
je ne peux pas le deviner
mais j'ai vu que la vice-présidente des
USA kamalaharis a effectué une visite
officielle en France pour en quelque
sorte s'excuser
c'est une insulte
ils envoient le second couteau pour
s'excuser c'est une blague
et vous savez quoi nous n'avons pas
d'ambassadeur américain en France
seulement un chargé de mission
il trouve le respect qu'ils ont pour
nous c'est beau
désolé de vous perturber
non non j'essaye de montrer le ridicule
de cette vision
il bloque les Champs-Élysées et il
balade le cortège cela coûte de l'argent
aux Français
comme si le vol de 90 milliards de
dollars était une faveur rendu à la
France
c'est très comique
de quoi être mécontent
je spécule enfin non j'ai lu que les
gens spéculent que dans les cinq
prochaines années
à cause de la révolution colorée contre
de Gaulle en 68 qui m'a choqué parce que
j'étais jeune à l'époque j'étais du
mauvais côté
la compréhension des révolutions
colorées et de leur fonctionnement
impliquent qu'au cours des 5 prochaines
années la France ainsi que les pays
associés
devra faire tous les efforts possibles
pour gagner petit à petit année après
année moi après moi minutes après
minutes
une plus grande indépendance afin que ce
genre de choses ne se reproduise plus
il n'y a pas d'autres solutions vous
pensez qu'il y a une autre solution
vous pensez que le fait d'être
continuellement pillé par les États-Unis
va rendre la France riche la population
en bonne santé et éduquée oubliez ça
il n'y a qu'une seule solution pour
arrêter le pillage c'est plus
d'indépendance
oui ou les atomisés
en effet vous avez la force de frappe
qui est j'imagine la pièce maîtresse
d'une armée européenne
il y a un grand homme français fondateur
du projet
eras
j'ai correspondu avec lui
un homme brillant absolument brillant
il y a maintenant 10 ou 11 ans il a émis
l'hypothèse que ce qui se passerait ce
qui devait se passer était que la force
de frappe devienne la pièce maîtresse
d'une armée européenne
donc je crois que lors de la négociation
avec Biden après le vol des 90 milliards
de dollars
que l'armée européenne
que la politique d'une armée européenne
est en train de se développer et
d'atteindre sa plénitude
on arrive à la fin de notre interview
est-ce que vous voulez qu'on parle de
quelque chose en particulier tous les
deux avec la communauté
si vous voulez parler de quelque chose
en particulier
juste une chose
je trouve que tout que tout vient de la
masse des gens absolument
la capacité d'invention
repose dans l'âme de la nation ou
pour ne pas utiliser un langage
religieux dans le peuple lui-même
et tout ce qu'il faut
c'est que nous parlions ensemble de nos
préoccupations
et cela crée les conditions
et social et politique d'un changement
historique
c'est tout ce qui est nécessaire nous
n'avons pas besoin de faire des efforts
spéciaux pour aller à la Sorbonne ou
autre bien que l'éducation soit
importante
mais discutons ensemble de nos
préoccupations
et vous verrez vous verrez que les
gilets jaunes se manifesteront à nouveau
dans d'autres domaines
dirige gilets jaunes parfait le
phénomène se manifestera encore encore
et encore c'est ma conviction
est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
recommander à notre communauté
sur la folie
[Musique]
j'aime
Georges Betty sur la mort
avec et j'aime bien
Friedrich Nietzsche
pour sa compréhension
d'être comment je pourrais dire ça
j'aime bien Friedrich Nietzsche
qui a compris que la croyance de pouvoir
diriger sa vie
augmente sa capacité à leur donner
on croit la voir dirigé soi-même c'est
moi qui l'ai dirigé même la pire chose
que j'ai pu faire dans ma vie c'est moi
qui ai fait
ainsi cela étoffe l'âme et vous donne
beaucoup de force
c'est important
alors ne tenez pas compte des personnes
qui vous disent que vous consommez trop
d'essence et tuer les oiseaux quand vous
allez au magasin en voiture oubliez ça
ne culpabilisez pas soyez pragmatique si
je vais à pied au magasin je ferai un
peu d'exercice et je pourrai peut-être
dire bonjour à mon ami que je croise en
chemin voilà la bonne occasion
pas le fait de se sentir mal parce qu'on
aurait utilisé un peu d'essence qui
aurait pollué l'air et tuer des oiseaux
cette absurde préoccupez-vous seulement
de la meilleure façon d'agir dans
l'intérêt de votre famille tout d'abord
et ensuite pour vous même
a conseillé à notre communauté
je n'en ai pas en tête il y en a trop
est-ce que vous avez un autre conseil
pour les jeunes générations
juste passé à l'action et ne tenez pas
compte des vieux schmottes comme moi
passer à l'action c'est une chose
vraiment fabuleuse
le temps
comment dit-on le temps en français
tue le temps le
conscience
votre guest votre air du temps est
tellement différent de celui de mon
époque quand j'étais jeune me
préoccupations étaient l'habitat
l'éducation
la distribution des richesses la
construction d'une nation parce que nous
étions juste après la deuxième guerre
mondiale et c'était là nos
préoccupations la cohésion d'un pays
offrir un système de santé offrir des
possibilités d'éducation à égalité pour
les hommes et les femmes c'était ça nos
préoccupations
votre side guys
votre air du temps est tellement
différent que je n'ai pas de conseils
qui correspondent qui conviennent à vos
conditions
car mon époque était trop différente je
crois qu'on dit que le passé est un
autre pays alors passez à l'action ne
prêtez pas attention à ceux qui
prétendent vous culpabiliser
quelque part
que c'est Satan qui veut que vous vous
sentiez coupable
la culpabilité
est une douleur destructrice provoquée
par les accusations d'autres personnes
prenez du recul et agissez selon vos
propres intérêts et ceux de votre
famille John thank you so much
[Musique]